The direct ones, well, we did a lot of work
because of the pandemic, we work
together as educators, employees of the
system, now when the children come, we
have to do different things, we
have many programs, how we
classify the students in the
schools
at 17, the main schools
that are doing  something different and a
lot we invest a lot in the leaders of
this system to improve what we are going to
do a curriculum new mathematics
also so many promises that
we have made now invested in nothing else
in the classes
to the schools but also in the sentence
8 in the  buildings also for when
the children come on the 9th of August all
the students that we are going to open the
schools when they come on the 9th or we are going to
be in class we are going to be prepared
if that is the same is what
the future of the children is saying now
what comes all the conditions that
we are doing now will be
closing the caps
what we have separated for  all the
children so that in the future we will
be better off if we are still looking for
teachers and driver employees but
we will be ready
by August 9 for all the
children to come to school thank you very much